achimura drives inside Mr lamb
theokachin rebound leading the break
again
kicks a back out Corner Cornwell Paul
puts it up air ball rebound Porter won't
go jokic miss his second one no good and
Coldwell pump comes away back door Bobo
pop layup this time he banks it in on a
foul and the nuggets have their first
lead of the game
[Applause]
relentless on the boards and a chance
for a three-point play Lakers need
timeout
[Applause]
Joker rebounding all on the floor and
then this time gets the basketball
and the Beautiful delivery
Chicago gets the contact and the hoopage
just broke a record that has been held
for 56 years most triple doubles in a
single postseason